so i want to be really careful about
this segment what i want to do
is i want to steal man or make the
strongest possible
left-wing argument against broad
lockdowns and stay-at-home orders
as a way to deal with coronavirus and i
want to be really clear
there are lots of really bad arguments
on the right
against lockdowns what would a left-wing
case against lockdowns look like that's
what i want to answer today
so as a reminder bad arguments against
lockdowns from the right
include things like only old people will
die and we don't really need to worry
about that that's a bad argument against
lockdowns
stay-at-home orders or government
tyranny or
like nazis or whatever no that's wrong
and that is a bad argument against
lockdowns
the left wants people to be unemployed
no that's a very bad argument against
lockdowns
stay-at-home orders don't save anyone no
that's a bad argument against lockdowns
the economy is simply more important
than people's lives or
we should be willing to sacrifice
grandma or
lockdowns are merely meant to hurt
donald trump's re-election chances
these are all terrible arguments against
lockdowns and stay at home orders i
think you get it
there are lots of really bad right-wing
arguments against stay-at-home orders
let me present maybe a more realistic
left-wing case against
the full lockdowns that some places have
been doing so
on the left we recognize as a guiding
principle essentially that an american
society and an american
in the american economy it is the
working class the working poor the lower
middle class blue collar workers it's
all these groups who are more vulnerable
who are more precariously sitting on the
edge between being able to
pay for their living expenses and not
and they are the first to get the shaft
from our economic system for lack of a
better term
and at the same time it is those exact
people who are most hurt
by broad stay-at-home orders it's not
really the white-collar workers it's not
the lawyers it's not the people who can
work from home
it's not brand managers and management
consultants the people most hurt by
stay-at-home orders are restaurant
workers grocery store employees
agricultural agricultural workers
delivery drivers
people in transportation uber and lyft
et cetera et cetera et cetera these are
folks who have less power to begin with
in our economy they have less of a
financial cushion to get through a
calamity
and who either lose their jobs or have
to work in dangerous conditions or see
their hours reduced
without extra pay thanks to the
stay-at-home
orders so if we think about who is most
hurt by a broad lockdown it's the very
people
that we on the left have prioritized
as it should be because they are the
most taken advantage of
now at the same time even though we've
had broad stay at home orders in many
places
we've completely failed to actually
protect the people most at risk
older folks people in nursing homes
long-term care facilities here in
massachusetts at one point
half of all deaths were in nursing homes
the average age of death
here in massachusetts as of yesterday is
82 years of age i don't i think i assume
that's
median i'm not sure how it's been
calculated but it's been widely
reported by uh health authorities 82 is
the average
age of death we have failed to protect
nursing homes and this is happening
nationally there are some states i told
you yesterday the day before
even hiding nursing home deaths which
over understates the problem even more
we've not done enough testing which from
day one would have been a fantastic way
to identify more cases quickly isolate
people
we didn't invest in fever clinics which
is a colloquial term basically places
for people who have the disease
but are not super sick that they need to
be in a hospital
places to isolate like south korea has
done while they recover
so if you want to make a left-wing case
against broad lockdowns the argument
would be
we could have skipped such a broad
lockdown
we could have stayed much more open in
terms of restaurants and some other
places
certainly large sporting events concerts
had to be canceled
but we could have kept more stuff open
could have kept it open with mandatory
masks
we could have much earlier spent way
more money
on safeguarding older folks long-term
care and nursing home facilities
and way more money should have been
spent early on testing from the
beginning so
this is not so much about blame i mean
you know there's blame to go around
the federal government has a huge amount
of blame state governments
have uh failed in many cases to protect
older populations
this particular segment is not about
blame we know there's plenty to go
around
but there are things that could have
been done now i want to be really clear
i'm not falling for this entire children
and young people aren't affected by the
virus
we are seeing children affected to some
degree
some with a kawasaki-like illness
we are seeing you know younger adults to
some degree affected
but the mortality rate for people under
65 particularly those without
pre-existing conditions or comorbidities
is infinitesimally small and you know we
hear about
healthy 42 year old died of coronavirus
uh yeah but understand that those
numbers are close to zero
and this is not like the flu in total
but sometimes you will get an
unexplained death from the flu
in a young healthy person sometimes it
will happen it is a tiny tiny fraction
so isolation stay at home for older
folks
of course way more testing of course
fever clinics for sick people of course
close large events of course
masks etc but there is a case that one
could make
that we could have if we were more
competently led at the beginning
we could have kept more things open
in a way that would have directly helped
the most
vulnerable workers in the economy while
changing the total risk very little we
could have avoided a lot of economic
destruction
now that is me still manning a left-wing
case against lockdowns
do i literally believe it one hundred
percent of course not of course not
one example lots of younger people live
with older people
so if you want to keep the young
restaurant worker employed
but their grandparents safe and they
live together
how do you do it right so it it doesn't
literally work
in all cases but i want to hear your
thoughts and the point
that i'm making is left-wing skepticism
of a total and complete stay at home is
okay
the right-wing skepticism and attacks
on the guidelines are ridiculous and
they're wrong
and they're laughable there is a
sensible conversation to have about how
it could have been handled differently
and it may be relevant
for when wave two happens if we have a
break between wave one and wave two
but we've got to actually think it
through and that's what i'm trying to do
with you right here
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at dpakman remember we have a
daily hour podcast that you can get on
itunes
stitcher google play and all of your
favorite podcast
apps make sure to sign up for it and let
me know your thoughts
on twitter where i am at deepakman
one of our sponsors nordvpn is giving
you
70 off a three-year plan which comes out
to just a little over three bucks a
month
and you'll get an extra month free when
you go to nordvpn.com
david pakman or just go to their site
and use the coupon code
david pakman it's 2020. there is really
no reason
not to be using a vpn not using a vpn
means
you are not taking your internet safety
seriously i use nordvpn
almost anytime i'm using the internet it
hides your ip address when you're
browsing online keeps you safe from
hackers
keeps websites from tracking your
browsing activity
many advantages and nordvpn is the most
trusted vpn
in the game they don't log your internet
activity
like many other vpns do their servers
are super fast and you can even use it
on your phone
nordvpn is giving you seventy percent
off a three year plan that's just over
three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
nordvpn.com
david pakman i've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code
david pakman